the Joe Rogan experience did you have a
dumb moment I had a lot of insights um I
don't know if I yeah I did actually
how many different trips did you have
while you're doing I had six or seven I
I so I just coupled to psilocybin trips
one guided one not an LSD trip guided a
couple ayahuasca circles and then I had
a really weird psychedelic all five Meo
DMT which is the smoked venom of the
Sonoran Desert toad who figured that out
you know if you get some kind of prize
but that's a pretty pretty potent one
very potent and thank God short acting
I'm short lived it was it was actually a
horrible experience really yeah that was
my worst yeah I had a great experience
you did yeah yeah so what was wrong with
it so I you know you take like one puff
and before you exhale I was and there's
a synthetic version too right I was
taking the venom you're shot out of a
cannon there's no lead-up it's no warmup
he's like fun
and I felt like I was actually like
strapped to the outside of a rocket you
know going through space and through
clouds and like the g-force was pulling
down my cheeks and it was just this
mental storm yeah without any nothing
orient myself there was no space there
was no time there was no self and it was
just unendurable this punishing roar in
my ears and someone who had done it said
eventually it's like a take off and you
get into orbit and and it's it's very
nice at that point but what happened
with me is I had the I had the storm I
mean I felt like it was like the
metaphor I use in the book is like I
said I can't explain this you can't tell
a story without place time and character
right I had none of those right it was
just this inchoate energy and I said it
was it was like the before the Big Bang
you remember that well obviously nobody
does but but there was pure energy and
no matter yet and no time yet I mean
that's where I was and it was horrible
I was terrifying and I thought I was
dying
but then you you come down as kind of a
suborbital flight and and then I started
coming down and suddenly I could feel oh
I got a body
you know it's touching my legs I have a
body and like oh there's a there's a
floor there's their space and then
there's time and the universe kind of
reconsolidated and I had this feeling of
incredible gratitude yeah not just for
being alive which all of us have had at
one point or another but that anything
existed I was I was grateful for the
fact that there is something and not
nothing because I'd seen what nothing
was like and so in that sense it ended
up kind of positive but you wouldn't
want to go there to have that experience
so subsequently somebody said to me a
very experienced psycho not who I was
telling this story to he said you didn't
have enough tell you really yeah because
you only took one hit usually take three
you take three and the rocket lied the
rocket ride leads you somewhere place
you make you take three three three
three three in a row
take a big time blow it out take a big
one blow it out take a big one and as
you're taking the third one you're
already seeing the world crystallize in
front of you it already starts turning
into geometric patterns you put the pipe
down lay back in the chair and you shoot
off to the center of the universe the
terrifying thing is you cease to exist
like it's the one drug that I've ever
taken where you don't you're not there
anymore even an end dimethyltryptamine
which is the difference between five
methoxy dimethyltryptamine is just an ox
acute oxygen molecule to it but NN
dimethyltryptamine is incredibly
visually stimulating five methoxy is not
yeah it's just white it was white it was
definitely I don't know how I could have
taken three hits because I hadn't
excelled the first one when I was gone
well I don't know what your I was
thought I only did the synthetic version
of it you're doing this and the person I
know who did the synthetic version had a
very different experience and they felt
like they were installed in the
firmament as this heavy star but I
didn't get there so it who knows I did
something wrong okay I don't think you
did I just think you had a different
experience and I mean I've obviously
there's got to be some sort of chemical
different you mean you're probably
getting other things in that frog venom
as well as pure DM that's right that may
be it yeah I don't know the answer
[ __ ] frog spit no no no frogs were
not good the making of this it's
excreted on the outside of their body
what most people know them yeah you you
rub them on a glass and then let it dry
off and then you scrape it that's right
glass it crystals yeah I heard you just
kind of squeeze them and then it sprays
the glass and overnight it turns into it
looks like brown sugar yeah it's an
amazing thing you're the first person
who knows anything about it that I used
to be able to buy it it was legal to
recently 2011 jug of this [ __ ] my god
flying I bought it from some company
American Chemical Company or something
and they send it to you and I had enough
to get the entire state of California
high for several days it doesn't take
much it doesn't but it's not something
you want to do very often it's and I
don't think it has the same kind of
healing properties because you're not
bringing back information that's usable
you did yeah I brought back a lot about
myself and one of the things that I
realized as I was I recorded what I
would do is post trip I'd hit a tape
recorder right when I became conscious
again and start talking about the
experience and what I remember saying
about the five methoxy DMT experience
it's like as I'm trying to recount what
happened I filled my ego trying to
retake hold the situation and even use
words in a way that might impress you
with my ability to describe things or as
you know as a professional comedian - I
was aware that like a lot of what you're
doing you're saying things in a way
that's pleasing to people so that they
get excited about hearing that time yeah
yeah and I was very aware of that while
I was doing that I was like I'm saying
I'm trying to explain things that are
not possible to explain because the
words that we're using we're all
invented for a world that doesn't exist
in the DMT dimension and once once you
break through it is so profoundly alien
that any word liberating yes yeah well
in a way I mean it may it may be really
truly realize that we are in a soup of
atoms and that it's not yeah there's not
like Michael Powell and Joe Rogan and
Jay
Vernon in a room here's a wood table
there's oxygen right now this we're in a
universal stew yeah diffused yeah and it
breaks those particles down or at least
it gives you a view into that and you
cease to exist which is the most bizarre
thing because it's so similar to end and
dimethyltryptamine chemically but so
different in an experience in fact that
you're not there while you're doing
regular D like and and
dimethyltryptamine which is the active
ingredient NIDA Wasco if you've done
that the pure version of it no not the
pure version the pure version is like a
very short much more intense ayahuasca
experience I've never done ayahuasca
I've only done the DMT version but the
blood injection or no smoking it but
when you what you get out of it is
you're there while this is happening
yeah you're just prone away like that's
true in your present but there's all
these entities of trying to calm you
down relax relax
take it in settle down settle down
they're all trying to calm you down and
and and and alleviate yeah it's it's
it's weird you know and they're also
[ __ ] with you like they give you the
finger like I had a bunch of Joker's
that were like dancing around me giving
me the finger
do you have machine elves - I don't
believe in that and I don't know what
that is like McKenna had those
experiences of machine elves I never saw
I saw it what I described is complex
geometric patterns that are made out of
love and understanding
they this seemed to me to be like the
building blocks of the soul all around
you all the time now some just gigantic
impossibly large infinite well of souls
just these things dancing around you and
they were they were never one thing they
would be one thing for a second and they
change into something else and they
change into something different and the
more profound the experiences God the
more profound the next one would be and
they kept saying like look at this look
at this like - but the words weren't
real words that's the other thing it's
like I'm saying the words look at this
and I would have that in my head but I
never heard anybody say it it was almost
like he was triggering those the the
concept of those words in my mind right
right it
it's pre or post linguistic some of
these experiences
[Applause]